Hello Peter.
Welcome back everyone it's charlie
this is going to be my new spider-man no way
home sinister six video all about the versions of
the sinister six characters that we see during the
trailer and now with the addition of all
these multiverse villains from the tobey
maguire spider-man movies and the andrew garfield
spider-man movies we actually have more than seven
members of the sinister six from various
versions of the team even tom holland said
you have no idea it gets so much crazier than
what you've already seen in the trailer footage
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there's a bunch of really big spider-man
stuff coming up in the next couple of months and
thankfully it actually seems like venom let there
be carnage is not going to be delayed now there'll
be a lot of spider-man stuff happening during that
but in a slightly different way so i'll talk about
that during my venom videos because it's not
really relevant for what's happening with the
sinister six in spiderman no way home but during
the spiderman no way home trailer as we all saw
the past couple of days watching it billions and
billions of times the trailer actually got more
views than the avengers end game trailer did it
just broke avengers endgame's record but during
the trailer you can easily spot at least five
of the sinister six villains pretty obviously
and when i said there were more than seven members
of the sinister six team various versions of the
team that's because of the other sinister six
villains from previous mcu spider-man movies
like spider-man homecoming and spider-man far from
home but the idea is now that between the tobey
maguire spider-man movies the andrew garfield
spider-man movies in the mcu spider-man movies
we now have enough characters for a relatively
comic book accurate version of the sinister six
here's the roster just going down the list and
i'll talk about the scenes from the trailer that
feature them just in case you missed them because
some of them are a little more obvious than others
starting with the most obvious ones green goblin
in dr octopus so the green goblin scene is this
pumpkin bomb getting ready to explode on the
bridge during spider-man's big fight with dr
octopus the green goblin laugh the cackle is
willem dafoe's voice i know there are a lot of
theories about it potentially being somebody
else i believe it's meant to be willem dafoe
it's his exact same cackle from the tobey
maguire spider-man movies and the exact same
pumpkin bomb technology that he used during the
first spider-man movie and those bombs don't just
explode they can do a number of different things
they can also destroy organic matter but it seems
like here they're just using them as straight
up bombs and i should have also prefaced this
by saying that yes i do think that a lot of the
trailer footage is cut in this to be misleading
they cut it out of order so that the way things
unfold the plot here isn't exactly the way the
plot of the movie plays out but the way they
cut this fight scene on the bridge they make it
seem like the goblin bomb is happening in the
same scene with the doctor octopus fight like
the sinister six villains have started to work
together in a loose team up at this point in the
film whenever this is happening and just like
the green goblin bombs being the exact same as
the tobey maguire spider-man version dr octopus's
arms are the exact same arms from spider-man 2.
there are a lot of you that are also asking
about the red lights on the arms because
during spider-man 2 the idea was that when
the arms were controlling him the lights in
the center of the arms were red and when dr
octopus was in control of himself the lights
in the center were white a lot of people were
just wondering after the trailer came out if dr
octopus in the movie here in spiderman no way home
is not in control of himself he's right listen
listen to me now because at the end of spider-man
2 he had regained control of his own mind from the
arms sacrificing himself and dying in the process
drowning in the river it's true we never saw the
body hit the riverbed but the whole idea was
that he wasn't going to die a monster as he said
he would die a good man so when he shows up in
the trailer with the red lights a lot of fans took
that to mean that marvel had not retconned his
story arc in the tobey maguire spider-man movies
and we're thinking that maybe he's a villain
now because it's not really him doing this
it's the arms that are in control or messing with
his mind somehow it's totally possible it's a
valid theory right now just because we don't have
that much footage so just something to consider
the whole thing with him knowing that tom
holland's peter parker is spider-man i think
it's just a trick of the way they edited the
trailer i think these scenes from him suiting up
in the iron spider suit and doctor octopus saying
hello peter are happening out of order i think the
green goblin doctor octopus attack happens then
he suits up in the iron spider suit to fight
then dr octopus shows up seeing spider-man and
because he learned toby maguire spider-man was
peter parker at the end of spider-man 2 and he
sees a spider person here facing him he probably
just assumes that it's peter parker under the mask
like oh spider person it must be peter usually
when it comes to stuff like this the simplest
explanation is the most correct one so that's two
big members of the sinister six people are saying
that willem dafoe's green goblin is supposed to
be the one to lead this mcu multiverse version of
the team in the comics it was actually dr octopus
who put the first verse in the team together maybe
they'll have a reference to that during the movie
where both of them are arguing about who's in
charge green goblin worked with the sinister
six but he wasn't part of the team till way later
with a different roster the next big core member
that original team jamie foxx's electro from
the andrew garfield amazing spider-man movies
as most of you have seen his energy is a little
more comic book accurate being yellow this time
so they have made a few minor changes in the name
of being more comic book accurate supposedly these
screenshots are of the sinister six villains in
the movie so there are some minor costume changes
famously kevin feige had a whole bunch of notes
when amazing spider-man 2 came out about the
electro character like there were just some things
about his character that he wasn't a huge fan of
so it sounds like they're using this movie as
an opportunity to correct some of those things
the other original sinister six villain that
you probably spotted here from the toby maguire
spider-man 3 movie is sandman when he's wearing
the black and gold costume getting blasted by
electro you see the earth rise up super huge and
seem like it's forming into a monster-sized face
most people believe that this is evidence of
sandman in the film for those of you that are
also asking about this red light here some people
are wondering if this is another spider-man like
andrew garfield or toby maguire the red light i
believe is actually just from one of the towers
that electro destroys so it's not meant
to be a second spider-man in this scene
the next big sinister sixth villain that we
supposedly spot on the trailer is the lizard
since the trailers come out so many people have
been all over instagram all over different social
media platforms trying to color correct and
re-light this scene in the sanctum with the
hand swiping peter and it does kind of seem
like the lizard also separately as some of
you have spotted it does seem like inside the
feast shelter here where spider-man seems like
he's chasing one of the villains he rips his mask
off zoom and enhance you can see what seems like
claw marks across his chest as if the lizard
has torn through his suit then even though we
don't actually see them fighting spider-man in the
trailer we still have mysterio himself there have
been lots of theories about him faking his death
the quentin beck mysterio but even if he is dead
william ginter riva stole all his mysterio
technology so he could become a new mysterio
either way you still have mysterio who was
one of the original sinister six members
then there's michael keane's vulture character
who's already shown up in the morbius movie along
with the tobey maguire spider-man suit michael
keane made it sound last year like he was coming
back during spiderman no way home but no idea if
it's just a small part a cameo or something larger
vulture was also part of that original sinister
six team then we also still have michael mando's
scorpion and the second version of the shocker
both from spider-man homecoming michael mando
made it sound like he was coming back at some
point and even though we do know sony is doing a
craven the hunter movie now on their own not part
of the mcu air taylor johnson is playing craven so
make all the quicksilver multiverse jokes but as
far as i know craven the hunter is not a character
in spider-man no way home but the point being
marvel does have enough characters for a very
comic book accurate version of the original team
inside the mcu using the multiverse in the tobey
maguire spider-man movies in the andrew garfield
spider-man movies and most of them are pulled
into the main mcu universe as a side effect of
peter and dr strange's spell and what's happening
with this mystery box what's in the box everybody
post all the memes the box seems like it's a huge
plot point the way they treat it in the trailer
with the spell as doctor strange is weaving the
spell and explains that in order to make the world
forget that he's peter parker one more day style
they're going to combine aspects of alternate
timelines where the world didn't learn his secret
identity but peter starts flipping out mid-spell
it seems like it messes with things just a little
bit here's the thing with doctor strange's
box though you notice that while the spell
is happening and they're manipulating alternate
realities alternate timelines when doctor strange
finishes the spell and seemingly takes them out
of this nexus point here like this place in the
basement of the sanctum becomes a multiverse
way station for a second he's left with this
little ball of woven energy and then it seems
like it represents the timeline changes and i
believe the idea is that he puts that energy into
the box the box itself as you'll notice has the
same symbol of agamotto on it that's on the amulet
and the same symbol in the window of the sanctum
so i believe it's part of the enchantment meant
to protect our reality like the enchantments in
all the sanctums cover the earth in a protective
barrier to prevent the multiverse villains like
dormammu or shumagorith from breaking into the
main mcu reality and because the lizard seemingly
is attacking spider-man here while this is all
going on in the basement of the sanctum while
they're messing with alternate universes a
lot of people are thinking that the box is
somehow this multiverse jail so to speak for the
sinister six characters like he's trapped them
within the box then we see spider-man trying to
pull a fast one on doctor strange them getting
into it over the box trying to open it like
spider-man's hand is stuck in the box while dr
strange is trying to separate him into his astral
form like hard pass timeout peter parker and it
might wind up being spider-man who inadvertently
unleashes the sinister six characters for real
thinking that if he releases the energy from
the spell it'll fix everything that he thinks
is broken like he changes his mind about the
spell no wait i want my friends to remember i
want mj to remember who i am i want everybody to
remember that i became an avenger because erasing
knowledge of his identity would also erase him
from the minds of the other avengers characters
so maybe he thinks that releasing the energy
here the doctor strange put in the box will fix
everything but secretly as you would expect local
man ruins everything it only makes things worse
releasing the sinister six multiverse characters
on this world and now the title no way home makes
a little more sense applying to both spider-man
and the sinister six character story lines because
it seems like spider-man has no way home to the
original timeline where he was in the relationship
with mj where he became an avenger like that's
the home that he's trying to get back to
and for the sinister six characters the multiverse
ones there's no way home theoretically to their
original universe is because if they were to truly
fix everything make it go back to the way it was
they go back to being dead because all these ones
died fighting their versions of spider-man so you
have to imagine green goblin sort of pitching them
on the idea of a sinister six team up like do you
want to go back to being dead well not really
in talking about the future of the mcu think
about it this way doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness is supposed to happen directly after
spider-man no way home and it's implied that the
multiverse will get even crazier during that like
as bad as it seems like it is during spider-man
no way home even worse during doctor strange 2.
as the title implies that also means that they
probably do not fix all the multiverse derps
before the end of spider-man no way home meaning
some of these tobey maguire and andrew garfield
characters are here to stay in the mcu for good
or at least until they get killed off like i said
there are more than the original six members of
the team in this movie there's so many characters
that means that they will probably wind up killing
at least one or two people in the movie and when
you think about the future of the sinister six
as a franchise by itself like spin-off movies for
sinister six characters remember back during the
andrew garfield era of spider-man sony wanted to
make a sinister six movie and that was not going
to be amazing spider-man 3. they were going to do
amazing spider-man 3 but also a spin-off sinister
6 film so it sounds like sony wants to get to the
point where they can do that new franchise again
like create new sinister six movies but have them
be completely different from the linear spider-man
sequels in spider-man no way home is just kind of
setting the stage for that making that possible
using the multiverse trope thank you very much
sylvie thank you very much king the conqueror
i'm sure there's still a thousand questions
about everything that's going on during the movie
as tom holland said this is just the beginning
like it gets so much crazier than this so we have
barely seen any of the movie even though it seems
like we know a lot about what's going on and
for those of you that are asking doctor strange
questions there are all kinds of rumors about
x-men fox characters showing up during doctor
strange 2 i'll probably do a separate video about
that at some point when we get some more evidence
and some more information about what's actually
happening next week's marvel what if episode 4
is also the doctor strange episode where we
learn about dark doctor strange so make sure
you have alerts enabled for my channel so you
don't miss any of those videos congratulations
the art of cass you're the giveaway winner from
my last big marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so i can get your contact
details everyone click here for my full spiderman
no way home trailer video and click here for
my brand new marvel eternals trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!